c'est deux un couple Juifs vieux Salomon
et s'arrachent l'homo et c'est Salomon
il dit ça va ça va tu sais quand on
était dans notre village en Pologne et
qui a eu le pogrom ils ont brûlé notre
maison est-ce que tu étais là il dit
mais bien sûr mon amour bien sûr que
j'étais là et quand il y a eu la Ralph
du beldi ils nous ont tous des porté
Auschwitz est-ce que tu étais là tu mets
mon amour bien sûr que j'étais là aussi
elle lui dit après quand on était à
Auschwitz c'est qu'on s'est évadé qu'on
a marché trois jours dans la neige et
pénazi nous ont retrouvé nous ont ramené
ce que tu étais là et tu mets bien sûr
mon amour j'étais là depuis le début
alors Sarah tu penses pas que tu me
portes un peu la poisse quand même
[Applaudissements]